the federal government confirms that
some people in the st. Louis area may
have a higher risk of getting cancer
a recent Health report found some
residents who grew up in areas
contaminated by radioactive waste
decades ago may have increased risk for
bone and lung cancers among other types
of the disease
now this assessment was conducted by the
agency for toxic substances and disease
registry that's a branch of the CDC and
our Warner's here with this latest
update to a story that CBS News has
covered since 2015 we're certainly on
top of it Anna good morning good morning
Gail in this situation is not unique to
st. Louis because it's connected to
America's development of its nuclear
weapons program decades ago the problem
is radioactive waste persist in the
soils and many people believe that's why
they or a loved one developed cancer now
for the first time federal health
officials agree on the record that's a
real possibility you'll never forget the
moment they tell you you we found
lesions on your lung in your liver that
was Mary osco three years ago as she
told us she'd been diagnosed with stage
4 lung cancer in 2013 despite never
touching a cigarette she's now on the
last drug her doctors can offer her to
hold her cancer at bay I'm not ready to
die yet I have things to contribute to
society
she and her husband Gerard are just two
of many residents here who believe their
families cancers were caused by
decades-old radioactive contamination in
the 1940s and 50s st. Louis was key to
America's nuclear weapons program the
government hired the Mellon Krotz
Chemical Company to process uranium used
to make the atomic bombs dropped in
Japan in World War two the radioactive
wastes from that processing were then
stored at sites in North County tens of
thousands of barrels many stacked and
left open to the elements contaminated
the soil and nearby Coldwater Creek it's
the Creek that sometimes flooded the
park next to the Oscars house now it
looks normal right but in your mind this
is gonna be normal looks can be
deceiving
the Army Corps of Engineers has cleaned
up two major sites and has spent years
testing hundreds of properties along
Coldwater Creek the testing and sampling
of self is extremely complicated program
manager Bruce Mun Holland says trucking
activities caused some of the
contamination they did not practice very
good techniques as far as hauling that
trucks were uncovered and things were
just allowed to proceed sloppily so all
along the howl room
debris would fall off the trucks which
means figuring out precise health risks
was a challenge for federal scientists
like Jill Dyken trying to get a good
estimate of what the contamination may
have been in the past was one of the
tougher questions that we had to deal
with
despite that Dyken and her colleagues
did find distinct potential risks that
for children who grew up near Coldwater
Creek or lived in its floodplain for
many years in the 1960s to the 1990s the
risk of some cancers may be higher in
particular for bone and lung cancers the
agency gave its results at community
meetings in June still many residents
were left with unanswered questions if
it picks up radioactivity traveling to
our homes have you evaluated that but
activist Kim byzantines says the report
marks progress we would like to see
additional areas testing in that study
gave us that opportunity her Facebook
group began tracking suspicious cancers
in 2012 and has pushed for health
studies for visit teen whose
six-year-old son died from a brain tumor
12 years ago the report gives much
needed confirmation them to acknowledge
that it is a possibility is a huge deal
three years ago the Army Corps of
Engineers found low level radiation in
the park next to the Oscars home it's
cleaned up now but they live with the
knowledge that their children grew up
playing there we didn't know that or we
wouldn't have bought this house so you
feel guilty
I do but you couldn't know but if I
would dump
left well some residents including the
AH SCO's are suing Mallinckrodt and
other companies that handle uranium and
radioactive waste Mallinckrodt told us
in a statement that at all times the
company worked under the direction of
the US government which has been
responsible for and is handling all
cleanup efforts on the sites and at no
time did Mallinckrodt own any uranium or
it's byproducts although that work ended
in the 1960s the Army Corps says it
could take decades to test for and clean
up all of the radioactive waste left
behind they're trying to hunt it all
down boy you feel the pain of Mary osco
just the words in the way she said it
Anna where she said I'm not ready to die
just because of where you live through
no fault of your own it seems so unfair
right they're just hoping that they
might there's a federal program that
might enable them to get some money
maybe fifty thousand dollars a family
which of course it's not what you care
about right now but this new report
means that they could have some progress
on getting some of that money
potentially at least something at least
tragic something yeah Anna thank you